Okay, from the chat, hi, is 100% pure turpentine for a parasite would help for anal cancer.
Well, there is a turpentine protocol for cancer. I know people know what.
Yeah, there is a turpentine protocol for cancer.
And turpentine was actually used to treat a lot of diseases back before,
before pharmaceuticals came out.
And then it slapped that, you know, so I don't know what that protocol is.
You'd have to Google that. I don't know what that is.
But, you know, don't disclose somebody's these kind of old school protocols for different things.
You know, a lot of them did it's work, and we're fully, but a lot of them did work.
So, I just talked to somebody on the phone about maybe two months ago,
that was doing the turpentine protocol for cancer.
And they've been doing it for a while, and they thought that's what was helping them to learn.
So that's the first time I talked to somebody doing that for cancer for a couple of years.
So that's the first time I talked to somebody doing that for a couple of years.